there's the old legends about uh you
know Disney right The Lion King he lays
down it says sex and then I think the
the official explanation was no no says
sfx is that what it was something like
that then there's not the cover of The
Little Mermaid then there's Aladdin
saying what do you say good what does he
say something about taking off your
clothes there's a bunch of wieners
everywhere
that's what it is
is it isn't it like The Great Mouse
Detective had something did it oh I
don't I didn't see that one I don't
think yeah I don't I could be wrong
because I I I I I learned all this from
watching some like newgrounds.com video
back in the day but it was like under a
care it was a small like porn frame or
something I don't know if that's real
but that's like another part of the
legend or whatever they've been working
this stuff but we saw it in 2012 before
the kind of whole transgender kind of uh
movement started taking off in America
we saw it being pushed at this school
pretty heavily and then of course you
see these major writers um you know
writing these series writing these
movies and they're part of this whole
scene and so we've been I think that
it's been been embedded within the
culture for a while we always wonder how
do these things happen they happen
because we've allowed the left and the
woke to monopolize all of these
institutions that Define what it means
to be American so you know I think
that's one of those kinds of things
where we the only way to fight back the
only way to push back is to create our
own institutions and get our own
messages out there here's what we're
doing one of the things that we're
working on here is aside from music and
you know cast castle like all of the
projects we've been working on have been
apolitical but one of the things we're
doing is we're setting up a physical
space which will probably be you know uh
we want to do like a gaming space board
games but we want to do events called
Saturday morning cartoons where Saturday
mornings you bring your kids there's
like a buffet of like catering pancakes
sausage waffles hash browns and then we
have like little arcade games but we
play cards tunes that parents approve so
we can bring back that you know we used
to wake up watching on Saturday morning
watch the cartoons and the cartoons
weren't so bad we want to bring that
kind of thing back and we want to create
a place where neighbors can meet each
other and hang out build community and
build a culture around you know where we
live It's Gold Rush right now I think as
far as um you know the right the way
that they see this all happening at
Disney and Netflix and what have you
they want other options they just don't
have the options out there for so many
years I would tell people do not you
know you know give money these people's
movies and their television shows don't
subscribe but then the the pandemic hits
and now people are stuck at home they
have nothing to do they have no other
options they need options we got to do
Jack's Pizza Shack Jax Jack's Pizza oh
yeah we do so big yeah Jack masobic uh
you know he talks about Pizza Hut
nationalism yeah yeah we drove past an
old Pizza Hut and it was all falling
apart it's kind of sad we ended up going
but uh maybe that's what we should do we
should set up you know Jack's family
friend lead Pizza Emporium or whatever
and then we can do community events
because that's another big aspect to
community so obviously we're doing
internet-based stuff we want to build
culture but you can also build culture
at the local level too Jack's been smart
Jack's been great about that back to
your point uh the sablono subconscious
propaganda does work and that's why they
they put these little messages in there
there's a reason advertisers spend
hundreds of billions of dollars trying
to get their messaging out there and
truly what happens with children
especially when it comes to Disney and
all these other Mega corporations and
the images and the messages and and
really the propaganda deep down when you
really look at it when you're able to
take a step back because when you watch
entertainment you usually go into your
kind of Reptilian Brain you don't think
you don't really you just kind of sit
there and consume it you're in this
phase where you're just getting injected
with entertainment it's not
entertainment a lot of it is propaganda
a lot of it is programming that programs
people to believe families are bad to
beliefs healthy relationships are bad
and as you said to make children in this
kind of state where of course they're
going going to be prevented from having
healthy relationships in the future but
but the culture is extremely important
we have to fight back I think memes are
also extremely important like the meme
that Tim just showed just a couple of
moments ago but there's another meme
that I that I saw today to bring this
back to the conversation that we
originally had here and it was of
Deutsche dog in the 1920s saying I lost
my house I lost my job I lost my savings
I lost everything and then you have the
[ __ ] Chad Deutsche dog in 2020 saying I
never had any of those things
and when you when you're seeing messages
like that in memes like that it
resonates with people because like yeah
I never had savings oh yes I don't have
a house yes I don't have a real job I
have I have this gig economy created by
Klaus Schwab in the world economic Forum
that literally is just screwing me over
and not giving me any kind of benefits
or anything that that could actually
sustain sustain me as a human being so
memes I think are super super important
Luke came to me before the show and he
was talking about him he was being he
was unhappy and I said considered owning
nothing oh yeah things are looking up on
the simplistic hippie Ian level that can
work actually yeah with minimalism I
live in an RV so I went into the whole
minimalistic aspect I you know it's
still impossible to pack that that whole
thing but but in in in in in a bigger
element yes but what they mean from it
is is essentially human slavery which
they're slowly conditioning us to be
okay with by getting rid of our
financial ability to prosper or have any
kind of legitimate healthy lifestyle so
when you're seeing people getting
screwed over I mean these inflation
numbers these are just the official
numbers they don't represent what
actually is happening out there in the
real world since uh last year groceries
went up 13.5 percent rent went up 6.7
percent airline fares 13.4 electricity
15.8 that's a lot higher than the 8.3
percent reported just in August what's
happening out there is a total bloodbath
the poorest people of the world are
being screwed over are literally just
being just taken by their feet and
shaken by all these globalists by all
these leaders that that just want
everything from them and it's disgusting
and it's sad and it the poverty the
homelessness the the suffering is
created by politicians and because we
don't see what's going on because we're
divided because we're conquered we're
allowing this to to yeah somebody just
super chatted a correction they said
it's Disney's The Rescuers it has a
frame with a woman in the window full
frontal Snopes
um you know I just think about where
we've gotten to you know with everything
Luke said I'm hearing you know all this
economic stuff and then I'm thinking
about what you said and imagining just
like all ages drag shows and I'm just
like Rome is Burning Man 100 so I kind
of feel like you know what you can do is
Scream as you fall to the Earth or or
you can enjoy it as you're skydiving
you know and then you know I guess do a
couple summersolves
you can scream and panic or you can aim
for those trees aim for the bushes yeah
aim for the bushes use your body as a
glider mechanism you know I've heard
like people have survived their shoots
failing like hitting falling into trees
and stuff so stories maybe maybe the
American revolutionaries had to fight a
war to seize their property back from
the king or basically
retain or gain the rights to their own
property that the king had seized from
them however you want to look at it and
to think that we might go back there is
really bothering me I don't like that
BlackRock or black stone has been able
to purchase uh yeah property I don't
think it should be constitutionally
legal for Mega Corps to buy property
that doesn't make sense to me maybe not
single parent single-family homes but
but I would say you hit the nail on the
head with the hammer um except for the
might part I mean look at the rate at
which we're taxed so there they were
concerned about much less taxes back
then than we get taxed today and it's
getting worse so man it's crazy to think
about this idea that after the American
Revolution you owned land that was it
you owned land now you can't own land
without paying a million and one taxes I
think the the real indicator is whether
we're going to just into a civil war or
not and we've talked about this on red
pill America a lot we've actually did an
episode on it we believe that we're
venturing towards that area we agree
with you on that I think the difference
is or what we're seeing right now if you
look at the American Revolution or you
look at these the actual Civil War in
the mid-1800s why did those things
happen they happen because the people
that were fighting didn't have political
recourse there was nothing that they
could do from a political standpoint to
change the things that they were trying
to change in the in the 1776 it was they
didn't have you know it was taxation
without representation in the middle
1800s it was oh you know we don't have
rights we're slaves uh we're seeing are
we seeing that now is that what we're
seeing is that there's no political uh
ability to solve our problems that's the
real question I think that we're
starting to ask ourselves right now you
know with people talking about voter
fraud and and those kinds of things if
people start to believe that they do not
have the political Pathway to solve
their problem they turn to violence and
that we've seen that throughout American
history so that's really the temperature
that we really need to be gauging is do
people feel that they can change thing
in the voting booth those who make
peaceful Revolution impossible make
violent revolution inevitable exactly so
if people look you've got uh we'll get
into this in a little bit but Lindsey
Graham is basically sabotaging the
Republicans right before the election
cool he's he's pushing out this 15-week
abortion ban which is it's not going to
pass it's impossible
Republicans don't have the house of
senate or the executive branch so this
makes no sense to do
if people start to feel like there is no
path towards any kind of political
solution you're right they're going to
lose their minds and it's going to get
bad but I have to wonder if this is what
they want he right before a midterm
election get everybody riled up and
angry so that they can sabotage of
course it's what he he wants I believe
and I think that the people that are
going to be backing him on this I mean
culturally is is there anything
culturally that's pulling him into
making this decision I mean it's that
whole that old saying that Andrew
Breitbart made popular politics is
Downstream of culture the only time that
you can create polit or create a
legislation like this is if the culture
asks for it you can try to create it you
can force it down people's throats but
the decision already has to be made by
the American people for that to stand
and Lindsey Graham I think is off on
this I don't think culturally right now
I mean the whole thing with Roby v Wade
and why we were so happy about it I
consider myself pro-life but the reason
why we were so happy about it is because
we were throwing it back to the States
and we were allowing states to make
their decision and now he comes along
and says no now we're going to to you
know enforce this on a federal level and
I he has to understand that this is
going to rile up the left he has to
understand it I mean just Logics just
logic will tell you that thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there